bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui et j'ai
décidé de vous parler de la souffrance
alors c'est pas un thème très joyeux
m'excuse par avance
alors pourquoi est ce que j'ai voulu
traiter ce thème de la souffrance
déjà parce que avec la vidéo sur
schopenhauer
j'avais un petit peu abordé la question
on se souvient que pour schopenhauer
la vie n'est finalement qu'une
succession indéfinie de souffrance et
que quand schopenhauer là la vie ne
mérite finalement pas d'être vécue
elle n'est que le résultat d'une
absurdité radical cette volonté cette
force que personne ne peut comprendre
et à bien y regarder plus l'homme est
conscient de cette absurdité et puis
souffre
donc finalement pourquoi poursuivre
cette souffrance de schopenhauer autant
tirer le rideau et cesser purement et
simplement dont se reproduire pour que
l'humanité à venir n'est pas à subir
cette souffrance
alors face à ce genre de conception
philosophique souvent il ya deux
attitudes
la première c'est de se dire bon sont
bien gentils ces philosophes mai
et ne voit que de la souffrance partout
là où il regarde à croire que il
projette sur le monde lors leurs propres
turpitudes leur propre malheur
peut-être que s'ils ont une vision
sombre de la vie
c'est peut-être d'abord parce que leur
propre vie était sombre
ça c'est la première attitude la
deuxième attitude consiste à dire que la
schopenhauer en tant qu' en tant qu'être
humain doué d'une conscience a priori
s'il pensait ça c'est qu'il avait des
raisons de le penser
comme on dit on peut accorder à
schopenhauer le crédit de ses intentions
et trouver dans ces textes un certain
sens
ça ne signifie pas dans ce cas la gauche
au point d'avoir raison et le contraire
ne prouverait pas que schopenhauer à
tort il s'agit simplement percer à jour
ce qu'il a voulu dire et c'est ce que je
vais essayer de faire dans cette vidéo
alors pour ça je vais partir d'un
postulat qui est de dire que nous vivons
dans un monde physique
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que tout ce qui existe à la surface de
la terre en tout cas où ce qui existe
avec une certaine certitude ce sont des
objets matériels sait confie le bois
objets pas s'appliquer également d être
des êtres vivants
donc si par exemple je considère ce sens
voiliers qui est en face de moi je
considère qu'il existe et qu'il a une
existence matérielle certaines
caractéristiques sensorielles que je
peux décrire et c'est ça qui finalement
ma forme de son existence
maintenant essayons d'aller un peu plus
loin de ce postulat essaie de dire que
tout ce qui existe dans le monde
physique dans notre monde existe à la
fois dans un certain espace et dans un
certain temps dans un certain espace ça
veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que ce cendrier toujours
que j'ai en face de moi il a des
contours
il a une forme il a en quelque sorte des
limites spatiales qui le contiennent
si bien que ce cendrier
s'il est en face de moi il n'est pas en
même temps ailleurs un objet ne peut pas
être à la fois là où il est et ailleurs
il possède ce qu'on pourrait appeler en
philosophie infinite u2 maintenant je
peux dire que ce sont briller qui est en
face de moi il a une existence qui est
aussi limitée dans le temps
pourquoi de tout simplement parce que
avant d'exister par définition il
n'existait pas il a donc été fabriqué il
a été conçu il a été amené à exister
matériellement à un moment donné
total se sont grillés va disparaître une
vaste anéanti physiquement alors déjà à
ce niveau là on pourrait me faire une
objection vous disons que oui certes le
cendrier en tant qu'objet un début il a
bien été conçu à un moment donné mais
les composants de ce cendrier eux ont
toujours été là c'est à dire que la
matière constitutive de l'univers n'a
peut-être pas de début on se souvient de
la phrase de la voisine qui provient
elle même au de l'entité rien ne se crée
rien ne se perd tout se transforme
d'accord tout objet qui vient à
l'existence
il est composé d'éléments matériels qui
le précédait et est ce que ces éléments
matériels
au commencement elle c'est pas une
question à laquelle on peut répondre
la conséquence de ce que je veux dire
c'est que tout ce qui existe dans le
monde physique s'inscrit nécessairement
dans ces deux dimensions l'espace et le
temps
maintenant si on revient à la question
de schopenhauer qui est de se demander
qu'est ce que la vie et la vie
n'est-elle pas finalement une fixation
souffrance
son part de ces deux postulants à savoir
la limitation fondamentale dont tout
être physique on part déjà on parle déjà
du mauvais pied
parce que cette idée de limitation on
sait quelle est la cause d'énormément de
souffrance chez les êtres humains on va
développer par la suite
et avant ça j'aimerais qu'on comprenne
bien cette idée qui est absolument
fondamental c'est que à partir du moment
où un être prend conscience de sa
finitude
il en souffre en somme si l'homme
n'avait pas de conscience ne serait pas
malheureux et l'âge où je reviens sur
cette phrase de la bible
heureux les simples d'esprit parce que
quelle que soit la traduction qu'on
puisse ce pour faire l'idée qui est
contenu est bien la même à savoir que ne
pas avoir conscience quelque chose qui
pourrait nous rendre malheureux nous
dispose d'être malheureux il est
beaucoup plus difficile de trouver de la
souffrance psychologique chez les
animaux encore que je sache que ça
existe cochez autrement on sait que le
fait de penser de réfléchir de prendre
conscience de certains malheurs existant
dans le monde ne favorise pas non plus
le bonheur et on sait aussi en tout cas
on peut prétendre je pense sans trop de
risque que plus un individu est
conscient puis peut se perdre dans des
labyrinthes intellectuelle et mentaux
et le fait d'envisager trop de
possibilités également une source de
souffrance puisque après tout quel est
le bon chemin or schopenhauer la
souffrance humaine est donc lié à la
conscience de l'absurdité l'existence de
la même façon lorsque l'on prend
conscience de sa finitude aux origines
sa double finitude dans l'espace et dans
le temps ne peut construire
alors ça peut paraître à saab semaine et
je vais vous donner des exemples qui je
pense vous parleront davantage eu la
finitude dans le temps c'est le fait que
l'homme un moment donné va naître vivre
et mourir
la naissance et la mort sont les
intervalles de l'existence humaine et
ces intervalles indique bien ses limites
la naissance ça devrait être une forme
de traumatisme on passe d'un milieu des
milieux aquatiques pourrait être
l'allégorie du paradis perdu à un
environnement hostile avec des gens qui
crient qu'ils aient vécu leur comprend
rien à ce qu'il raconte mais voilà on
sait qu'on va devoir vivre parmi eux
donc on essaye de s'adapter
si la naissance c'est un traumatisme la
mort est un traumatisme pour eux
peut-être l'idée de la mort ils sont pas
prêtes ou en l'absence de témoignages on
ne sait pas si la mort est un
traumatisme mais l'idée de la mort à
coup sûr éveille chez l'homme des
angoisses certains comme freud eux
diront que c'est justement pour résoudre
cette angoisse que l'homme a inventé
dieu qui lui permet de croire dans un au
delà
on sait que le temps est un traumatisme
pour l'homme
alors aujourd'hui ça peut s'exprimer
dans des choses très très vial comme la
lutte contre le vieillissement
je parle ici du vieillissement
esthétique mais également les progrès de
la médecine indique que l'homme a
toujours cherché à repousser les limites
de la mort ça peut paraître une évidence
mais c'est une évidence qui mérite
d'être formulée c'est à dire que si
l'homme a toujours cherché à repousser
les limites de la mort c'est bien parce
que la mort constitue pour lui un
problème ce n était pas un problème
l'homme passerait son temps à autre
chose qu'à lutter contre la mort
passerait par exemple son temps à faire
en sorte que sa vie soit agréable ou que
sa vie soit complète afin de ne pas
avoir à affronter la peur de la mort
d'abord est un pro mathis mme laborde
est une angoisse puisque la mort à un
niveau individuel ce n'est rien moins
que la fin du monde savait qu'on spécule
beaucoup sur la ou les fans monde mais
peut-être qu'avant de se poser la
question de la fin du monde on ferait
bien de se poser la question de la fin
de notre propre monde qui est le jour de
notre mort et qui va arriver tôt ou tard
prendre conscience de cette idée et ça
parce que je suis en train de faire
d'ailleurs un petit peu malicieuse c'est
la source d'une grande souffrance
en réalité ce qui est d'ailleurs
intéressant de noter c'est que on ne
souffre pas à l'idée de la mort
lorsqu'on ne pense pas évidemment que ce
n'est donc peut-être pas la mort qui est
un problème mais son idée on peut
importe
toujours est il que la conscience de la
finitude même a poussé l'homme à lutter
contre cette fille
et de cette manière toute l'histoire de
la culture mais peut-être un autre que
sept buts de l'homme contre sa fille
tuée
a besoin de se surpasser en permanence
un besoin d'aller au delà et vous verrez
qu'on ça vous fera écho dans la suite de
notre
profitez de la limitation dans l'espace
bon je n'ai pas besoin de développer si
vous êtes ici vous n'êtes pas ailleurs
combien de fois avez vous vécu cette
sensation très désagréable de vouloir
être quelque part où vous n'étiez pas de
vouloir quitter le repas de famille qui
s'éternise loi à partir de votre travail
votre pas trop mal même bref l'on vit
d'ailleurs non-vie d'évasion envie
d'exotisme
ça revient un peu à ça cette envie qui
précisément n'est pas satisfaite parce
que vous ne pouvez pas être à deux
endroits différents en même temps là
encore l'homme amdh a tenté de mettre en
place des subterfuges pour contrer cette
finitude
par exemple le moyen de locomotion on a
nous commencions sait si bien le fait de
se mouvoir de se déplacer ce qu'on
constate quand on observe l'évolution
justement de la technologie de transport
c'est le fait que les distances puisse
être parcouru de plus en plus rapidement
qu'on a une sorte d'association ici
entre la lutte contre la finitude
spatiale et contre la finitude de
temporal et on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
se poser la question mais qu'est ce qui
a poussé l'homme à développer et à faire
évoluer cette technologie avec autant
d'enthousiasmé beaucoup de temps et
d'énergie de vigueur et bien c'est le
besoin de réduire la finitude spatiale
certains diront que c'est un c'est le
moyen simplement de satisfaire un désir
de conquête désir de conquête des
territoires inconnus
oui c'est exact mais ce désir de
conquête n'aurait pas de sens si l'homme
n'était pas marquée par cette finitude
spatiale et temporelle
ça ne serait pas un désir si c'était à
portée de main
cette double finitude l'homme en a
conscience en tout cas l'homme
historique c'est à dire l'homme dans son
développement collectif à travers
l'histoire en a conscience
justement précisément par les exemples
que je vous ai donné ses besoins sans
cesse de dépasser les limites de se
surpasser d'aller au delà lui même ça je
vais le mettre en relation avec une
phrase de jean-paul sartre st jean n'est
pas toujours dit que du bien mais après
tout aussi savoir se réconcilier avec
ses anciens adversaires
jean paul sartre disait l'homme se
définit essentiellement comme projet et
il fallait entendre ou au projet presque
en deux mots c'est à dire 1 g en avant
projet j'ai en avant ça signifie que
selon sartre l'homme n'est jamais et
finalement identique à lui même il est
toujours désir d'au-delà dos de
l'abdomen
quand on se projette c'est con son
visage dans un futur par exemple dans un
autre lieu aussi par exemple
le fait de se projeter c'est ça qui qui
constitue l'essence même de l'humanité
c'est le fait de ne jamais se satisfaire
de sa situation présente
c'est le fait de toujours pouvoir
repousser les limites de la finitude
lorsque sartre défi l'homme comme projet
il le définit comme être en lutte contre
sa finitude
je vais maintenant passer à la deuxième
étape de mon propos qui va concerner la
thématique du désir
si l'homme et projets si l'homme et
lutte permanente contre la finitude et
bien ça se manifeste à travers cette
force qu'on appelle le désirent dans ma
précédente vidéo sur les piqûres isme
j'ai donné une petite définition du
désign que je veux reprendre le désir
c'est une force intérieure me pousse
vers un objet revue de se l'approprier
ce que j'ai désiré chose je désire le
faire mien
c'est ça que je désire on peut le voir
du point de vue opposés c'est à dire que
le désir c'est le désir de rejoindre
quelque chose le désir est toujours
désir d'eau donc le désir de
s'approprier quelque chose une désir de
rejoindre cette chose au final ça
revient un peu au nord ça revient à
vouloir faire quand avec l'objet
j'aimerais me laisser aller à une
divagation linguistique à savoir que le
mot désir et le mot désastre sont en
relation étymologique qu'ils ont la même
racine
le désir serait donc désastre mais le
désastre se serait littéralement la
perte de l'astre désastre
la perte de l'astre on sait que sur le
plan chimique l'homme est composé
d'éléments provenant de projection
stellaire revenant des toiles
ça c'est quelque chose que j'invente
pouvez le vérifier
et ces éléments chimiques qui sont à la
base de l'être humain
ils ont donc nos origines seles on sait
que l'astre en poésie est souvent
associé aux au paradis perdu à l'origine
d'un produit chimique l'homme vient des
étoiles d'un point de vue politique
l'homme vient des étoiles
peut-être que d'un point de vue
philosophique l'homme vient des étoiles
c'est à dire que l'homme a perdu son
origine
il a perdu son unité
si l'homme est une projection stellaire
faut imaginer une projection des
composés être de l'humanité que la
décomposition des astros auquel cas
notre aspiration profonde serait de
rejoindre cette unité
maintenant si on applique cette vision à
ce qu'on est en train de dire sur le
désir
on pourrait croire que le désir c'est
cette force qui anime on peut ce qui vit
qui donc animent l'être humain vers une
sorte de retour à un monde idéal de
retour un paradis perdu est bien dans ce
cas l'art la culture et l'histoire ne
serait que la lente marche de l'homme
vers la reconquête de l'unité
le désir est tojours désir de ceux qui
mentent
si quelque chose nous c'est qu'on estime
en avoir besoin
c'est qu'on estime qu'elle fait moi
partie de nous
aimer quelqu'un c'est aimer notre moitié
mort on s'est aimé celui ou celle qui
nous rendra complet
l'amour est souvent associée à cette
unité par l'harmonie c'est à dire par là
la complémentarité
s'ils le désirent et désastres le désir
et cette force qui nous pousse à
retourner vers l'unité
à partir de là tout désir est la marque
de notre puissance et de notre finitude
tous désirent est la preuve que nous ne
sommes pas complet je vais faire un
petit retour sur lui dès son origine
dans le banquet plateau met en scène des
personnages qui débattent la question de
l'amour et du désir et un moment donné
l'un des personnages évoque le mythe des
ombres jeu qu'est ce que c'est mal le
mythe des androgynes
c'est une histoire qui est censé
raconter le l'origine de notre humanité
et qui consistait à dire que à l'origine
tous les êtres était hermaphrodite
c'est à dire qu'il possédait les deux
sexes donc à la fois homme et femme y
compris du point de vue de leur forme
voilà il faut imaginer en fait deux
êtres dos-à-dos collés l'un à l'autre
donc il se retrouve avec quatre jambes
quatre bras et ses rangs et qui se
déplacent de manière circulaire fait
assez étrange mais l'idée c'est que les
être à l'origine et étaient des êtres
coquelet c'est à dire à la fois mâle et
femelle dont il ne leur manquait rien et
limites raconte quand ces épreuves ces
êtres surpuissant c'est être surpuissant
ont voulu se confronter aux dieux ils
rusent confrontés aux bisons il se
mesurait à eux parce que sur de leur
toute puissance
ils pensaient qu'ils allaient vaincre
les dieux et jupiter aux personnes s'est
déplacée pour dire les hermaphrodites
saleh les androgynes
vous n'allez pas faire long feu donc
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il les a coupés
en deux et là il les a regardés en
disant ben voilà vous êtes bien malin
maintenant vous vous êtes crurent les
égaux des dieux parce que vous étiez
puissant vous voilà divisée vous voilà
séparer séparer de votre moitié
séparé de votre partie manquante vous
êtes donc condamnés à passer votre vie à
rechercher votre routine en compte
je trouve que c'est très belle métaphore
du désir est une très belle métaphore de
l'amour
on en paye des grands mots parce que
cette recherche de la partie manquante
cette recherche de l'alter ego elle est
à mon sens très très emblématique de ce
que cherche à faire l'homme à travers
l'histoire qui de rejoindre sa partie
dit je n'emploie pas ce mot dans un sens
religieux pose pas la question à savoir
si dieu existe ou pas je pose même pas
la question dans ces termes là je prends
acte du fait que pendant longtemps les
hommes ont déclaré être guidé par dieu
et si on prend leur mot au sérieux on
s'aperçoit que c'est qu'aux héros c'est
cohérent de construire des pyramides
pour refaire des interfaces entre
l'homme et dieu c'est cohérent de
construire des cathédrales pour là
encore créer des interfaces entre l'âme
et du seco héros de rechercher la
formule mathématique qui permettra de
comprendre les lois de l'expansion de
l'univers
là encore
c'est vouloir se rapprocher de dieu
c'est à dire vouloir se rapprocher de
cette perfection idéal bref dans tous
les cas si l'homme n'était pas animé
d'un désir d'un désir ardent pour
surpasser sa propre finitude et
rejoindre sa partie manquante pour
devenir un être complet si l'homme
n'était pas donné cette force qu'elle
deinove est notre broderie ne ferait
rien ils n'agiraient pas et je pense que
vie serait un peu ennuyeuse
maintenant troisième volet de cette
petite réflexion comment se manifeste ce
désir et qu'est ce qu'il dit de l'homme
est bien ce que dit le désir de l'homme
c'est que l'homme de francs l'homme
souffre parce que s'il était heureux
il ne chercherait pas à être autre chose
que ce qu'ils ne ne chercherait pas à
dépasser ses limites
ne chercherait pas devenir meilleur tout
le monde est d'accord pour dire que
devenir meilleur est une ambition
parfaitement respectable qu'il faut
encourager
mais si l'homme peut s'améliorer
c'est bien la preuve qui n'est pas
parfait
et est-ce qu'on atteint réellement dans
sa vie un moment où on peut se dire ça y
est ça y est j'ai atteint le niveau
parfait non plus besoin ce qu'ont pu
besoin d'évoluer bien sûr que non
bien sûr que non ce qui est bien la
preuve que l'homme passe toute son
existence à être un parfait
leur philosophie et le concept c'est la
perfectibilité le fait de pouvoir se
perfectionner pouvoir être meilleur la
perfectibilité est d'abord la marque de
la finitude et tout désir en tant que
force qui nous pousse à aller au-delà de
ce mois c'est la marque de notre
finitude
c'est pourrait-on dire la marque de
notre misère la misère humaine
c'est la perfectibilité
la misère humaine c'est d'avoir
conscience de notre finitude donc tout
désir peut évidemment être vu comme une
force impétueuse magnifique une
expression de l'élan vital mais tous
désirent peuvent être vues comme la
marque de notre finitude
donc quand schopenhauer dresse un
tableau funeste du monde et de
l'humanité
mais c'est peut-être ça qui l'est c'est
de dire il essaie peut-être de dire que
la volonté
il appelle à voter cette force cette
force un fil et est totalement
insaisissables incompréhensible cette
force qui anime le monde
ben cette force-là elle est bien
l'expression d'un manque cette force là
qui s'exprime au travers de chacun de
nous elle est l'expression d'un monde
le désir est toujours désir de quelque
chose qui le complète
voilà pourquoi prendre conscience de ce
désir c'est finalement s'exposer à
allonnes et des plus grandes souffrances
cette souffrance on ne peut s'affranchir
quand l'oublions et encore je répète
inlassablement cette situation pascal un
roi sans divertissement est un homme
plein de l'isère l homme ne trouve pas
le moyen de détourner son esprit de
l'idée de la mort d'al être condamnés à
la souffrance donc vous voyez qu'on a
parcouru du chemin
à partir de l'idée idée de schopenhauer
que la vie n'était finalement que l'on
france et la conclusion qui est que si
l'homme souffre c'est parce qu'il est un
être de désir en ayant conscience
voyez que finalement lorsqu'on parle du
désir on ne parle pas forcément de
quelque chose de positif est que le
désir pouvant être vu comme désastre il
ne faut pas sous-estimer la capacité
qu'a le désir de se retourner contre
nous sous la forme d'une souffrance
les êtres qui souffrent sont des êtres
dont le désir se retourne contre eux
nous sommes les êtres qui souffrent sont
des êtres en bonne santé puisque la
force son beurre désir est là pour leur
rappeler qu'ils sont vivants
ce que je voudrais dire pour terminer
c'est que si on adopte ce paradigme
expert en existe que je ne vous décrire
on pourra considérer que le bonheur
consiste dans leur peau c'est à dire
dans l'immobilité chez les grecs
l'unité était associé à l'immobilité
pourquoi parce que pour qu'il y ait du
alité pour qu'il y ait deux objets des
objets distincts bien il faut bien que
un espace se soit établi entre ces deux
objets donc deux objets ça suppose
l'espace la dualité un pic l'espace
n'était l'appliquent pas l'espace
puisque l'unité est une totalité et qu'
il n'ya pas d'extérieur à la totalité
mais si l'unité est immobile ça veut
dire que la dualité est essentiellement
mouvement la caractéristique principale
de la vie c'est le mouvement
c'est à dire le fait de se déplacer dans
l'espace pendant un certain temps
l'homme est un être de désir parce que
l'homme est un être mobile
l'homme est un être qui agit en agissant
il se déploie dans l'espace le symbole
qui représente le mieux l'être humain
c'est la flèche la flèche indique bien
cette idée de mouvement
elle indique bien cette idée de
commencement et de fin elle a dit bien
cette idée de propagation de l'espace
autrement dit elles indiquent bien que
les caractéristiques du désir c'est à
dire le désire on l'a vu est toujours
desire 2 quelque chose il instaure donc
une dualité entre lui et son objet il
vise l'objet de manière à pouvoir se
réunir à lui il ya donc dans l'idée
d'une impulsion
au contraire le repos l'immobilité pour
être symbolisée par le cercle on pourra
rappeler à toutes fins utiles que le
cercle c'est la seule figure géométrique
qui ne possède qu'un seul côté
géométriquement donc le cercle peut
représenter l'unité est ce que l'homme
ne serait pas ou flèche cherchant à se
resserrer sur elle même pour former un
cercle l'homme dans son développement
historique est compris dans son
développement individuel on pourrait
dire qu'il avance vous savez cette
expression on avance dans la vie
l'histoire avance et cette idée d'avancé
on peut la mettre en lien avec la flèche
et peut-être que cette avancée peut-être
que cette évolution interne
ces termes ce serait le retour au point
de départ sur le cercle
retour au point de départ lorsque la
flèche aura parcouru tout cas courbure
du cercle pour finalement revenir au
point de départ un petit peu comme un
globe-trotter ferait le tour de la terre
pour revenir au point de départ
mais est il revenu au point de départ
non parce qu'il a avancé si bien que son
point de départ est devenu son prêt
d'arriver
la différence elle n'est pas
géographique elle n'est pas géométriques
elle est simplement lié à ce qui s'est
passé entre temps et entre temps on a
parcouru le cercle parvenir au repos à
l'immobilité parvenir à l'unité et à la
vérité c'est faire le tour du cercle
pour se rendre compte que on connaissait
la réponse des départs mais avec la
conscience d'avoir parcouru quelque
chose autrement dit le point d'arrivée
serait un peu le point de départ plus
expérience on peut peut-être voir toute
l'histoire de l'homme sous cet angle le
désir étant la force qui pousse la
flèche aller de l'avant cette force ne
seront peut-être pas compte qu'elle est
en train de former un cercle
c'est à dire qu'elle est en train de
travailler au retour à l'unité
j'espère ne pas vous avoir trop fait
souffrir
je redis à très bientôt
[Musique]
où